this is jocko podcast number 283
with echo charles and me jocko willing
good evening echo good evening
jumping into combat lessons we've done
some combat lessons before
we've done volumes one two and three on
this podcast
i'm skipping ahead a little bit to
volume seven there's a section in here
that i kind of got
kind of got into these these
combat lessons were written during world
war ii
with the explicit intention of
disseminating
lessons learned rapidly back to the
troops
to keep more guys alive and kill more
enemy and you might think and i started
thinking like why am i reviewing these
now why am i reviewing number four why
am i doing that
i'll tell you why because i've never
heard these lessons before
think about that i was in the military
for 20 years and i never heard these
lessons before
there's something wrong with that
there's something wrong with that these
guys these are lessons written
in blood in the hardest combat
imaginable
and they're not getting passed on so i
want to make sure
i pass on these lessons and you know
what obviously they're not just for
combat
not just for combat you're gonna see the
translation to every
situation that a human being in a
leadership position can be in
so combat lessons
the the volumes are getting better the
first one was kind of like a little bit
i'm not going to say it was
haphazardly put together but now you got
the full
cover picture you know there if you're
looking at this on youtube you've got
the cover picture up there combat
lessons
combat lessons number seven rank and
file in combat what they do
what they are doing and how they do it
the uh the intro to this thing to this
book
comes from i'll just read it
our armies in europe have won their
victory so this is late in the war
victory in europe already so now we're
just fighting in the pacific theater
veterans of the campaigns of north
africa and europe are now
joining forces with the veterans of the
pacific for the final assault against
japan
can you imagine having that on the
horizon
you're you're you're thinking okay we're
going
final assault on japan on the japanese
empire
we're gonna kill all them because they
fight to the death that's what's about
to happen
they don't these they don't know
anything about the atomic bomb yet
that's not even
an option they've seen the japanese
fight to the death
on island after island and now they're
gonna go
and assault the japanese island
itself the island of japan back to the
book they are coming to grips with a foe
quite different from the german soldier
different as an individual fighting man
and different in
the tactics employed even the most
experienced soldier of the european
battlefields
will have much to learn humility you
imagine you get done with
normandy d-day the battle the bulge
and you show up in the pacific theater
you got a lot to learn kid
dang we must now bring to bear against
the japanese
all the experience we have gained in
every theater the suggestions made in
combat lessons are drawn from such
expert experience
since to be effective they must reach
the soldier promptly
publication is not delayed to ensure
that they always represent
the thoroughly digested views of the war
department
the great combat lesson learned from
every operation
is the importance of leadership our
equipment our supply and above all our
men
are splendid aggressive and determined
leadership is the priceless factor
which inspires a command and upon which
success
all success in battle depends
it is responsible for success or failure
leadership is the most important thing
on the battlefield
by the way signed by general marshall
five star general
three no four no five star general
churchill called general marshall the
organizer of victory
the organizer of victory of world war ii
let's think about that that's a pretty
good compliment
coming from churchill uh this is a guy
that was a platoon and a company
commander
in in the philippine war
ended up being a secretary of state
remember learning about the marshall
plan
no well when you were in high school at
some point you learned about the
marshall plan
you just don't remember it uh it was
like the world war ii is the
it was the recovery the rebuilding after
world war ii
overseas in europe that the marshall
plan
named after this guy he got a nobel
peace prize for that by the way
so a a a very capable man so
kicking it into the book here leadership
first section leadership too much stress
cannot be placed
upon the necessity for developing
intelligent aggressive troop leaders in
all echelons so says general omar
bradley commander of the 12th army group
i wanna i wanna i wanna say that again
too much stress
cannot be placed there's no way you can
you can
stress the necessity for developing
intelligent
aggressive troop leaders and where
in all echelons in all echelons
squad leaders
however to use the battlefield as a
school room for the training of leaders
is to sacrifice needlessly the lives of
our men the habit of command and the
technique of troop leading
must be learned thoroughly by all
leaders prior to entry in combat
not only must leaders learn their own
jobs thoroughly
but they must also be given ample
opportunity to operate
in the command capacity of the next
higher echelon in order to
in order that qualified replacements
will be available
so if you're running a business i said
there's some similarities if you're
running a business and you're not
investing in your leadership
you're wrong and throwing them out to
the wolves
throwing them out to the clients throw
them out to a building site
without any training and preparation or
without any mentorship while they're out
there is the wrong move
by the way that's why echelon front
actually exists
that's why we exist to help that process
take place
the junior leaders responsibility field
leaders constantly emphasize the need
for junior officers who will share the
responsibilities of their superiors
and take charge when emergencies arise
in battle
check this out here's a note you're
young
you're you're new to the company
you're inexperienced in some way or
another way
if you have the willingness to pay
attention and then
start taking responsibility and start
taking ownership of things
you will go places now look you can't
you got to be you don't want to go
overboard with it
but if you see your boss has got some
things that maybe you could take over
for them
take them over i have a question
go about extreme extreme ownership and
this this might be splitting hairs
but in the spirit of understanding so
let's say whatever you come to me um
and or whatever i'm taking ownership of
a mistake
that happened okay right what if
i do i am like i'm not blaming you but i
am defensive
i am whatever i am all that but i
actually do
at the end of the lecture or whatever um
i do wanna i do at the end of the day i
do
think that the mistake was my fault
hundred percent
and i'm going to take it upon myself to
fix the mistake
okay but i handled the initial lecture
wrong
is that still technically extreme
ownership
why am i lecturing you i don't know like
uh like uh
you know i messed up the project okay
you know you failed the project and then
and i come to you and say hey echo
it looks like we're not gonna get this
project done on time yeah is that right
yeah yeah like or or let's say we
straight up didn't it failed okay
oh echo i see that we failed to
to get this project done yeah
did you get the support that you need is
there anything that i should have done a
better job of to make sure you had what
you needed to get this thing done
because this is a big letdown for the
client yeah and this isn't the kind of
reputation we're looking to have
where did i let you down okay so that's
you taking ownership right extreme you
know
and you're like okay so what if instead
of that
good lecture you were like hey you
messed up
and you you know like you did this and
you said yeah you you failed this
project
that's that's pathetic i'm thinking
about maybe demoting you yeah yeah
and then let's say okay after you
lecture me you think in your head you
know what this is my fault
this actually is my fault and i'm going
to do everything i can to
to correct this you do after you lecture
me
wrong with you but then i realize i'm
wrong yes and then i say you know what
there's some things i could have
probably no no you don't say that part
okay
you don't say nothing to me you just
kind of at you basically the whole thing
you learned the lesson you
get you failed the first part but it's
like you know parts of them
you fail the first one but you succeed
in the second
one okay but then i but then i opt not
to take ownership for some reason
with your verbal uh you can see where
you can see where this is
what's interesting about these questions
that you're trying to
formulate is how quickly they dissipate
when the person legitimately takes
ownership right all like when i
said okay so i say to you hey echo where
did i not support you all of a sudden
you didn't even have an argument you
didn't have a question anymore it was
gone
so you had to get me to say things wrong
to you yes yes and then
and then you want me to like switch
halfway because i'm just a crazy person
right so that's where we're at right now
we're just fine okay so
what's the hypothetical point that we're
trying to get at uh
well i guess if i if i learned anything
from you
right now and in the past it is that you
do
if you're gonna take ownership extremely
if you're gonna
demonstrate that practice that there's
two parts of it
and that's sort of it there's two parts
of it you
the way you come at the person or
whatever you let them know that it's
your fault kind of thing
and then the second part is you for real
it is your fault in your mind it is it
is your responsibility to take action to
fix those problems
not the kind of so your question is when
i come at you and say you failed this
project
you go well it was a big project so you
get defensive at first right yes
because you take it the wrong way sure
and you don't remember to take ownership
for another
two minutes the whole thing the whole
time you forget to take
ownership and then two minutes you know
what you do
you go you know what you know what boss
i'm getting defensive because my ego is
getting in the way and this is actually
my fault and all these excuses that i'm
making right now make no sense
whatsoever
here's here's the mistakes i made here's
the things i'm going to do to fix it i
will not let this happen again
yeah problem solved yeah so without that
second
recovery part i'm talking about the
interaction between the two people
that alone not that subsequent actions
that you're going to take to solve the
problem i'm not talking about that
because you're going to do that anyway
yeah but that
second verbal part interaction part
without that
that technically does not fit does not
fulfill the formula of extreme ownership
what do you mean without that second
part which second part the part where
you're
where you explain to the person that you
have the interaction with
like oh that was my fault and my ego's
getting in the way like not that part
straight up you left the meeting like
straight up like
we got scolded okay whatever then and
then you say this wasn't my fault and
you leave
yeah yeah you have to take ownership of
that that's the point of your extreme
ownership but in your mind you're like
wait it is my fault yeah then you go
back and then you say hey this is
that's what i'm saying okay so you do
that that interaction is part of the
yes yes yes it is you have to
i mean otherwise you're just making
excuses and blaming other people and i
don't trust you by the way yeah i'm like
oh echo screwed this up but he doesn't
even realize that he screws up he thinks
it's everyone else's fault
he doesn't take ownership cool i've
never given him another project again
yeah
whereas you come back and you say you
know what boss this is this is
completely my fault and then i let my
ego get in the way and i got mad
yeah my temper and my ego i will not let
that happen again
boom problem solved i understand
check all right moving on
comments major general john p lucas
commander of six core prior to battle we
must develop the feeling of
responsibility in junior officers and
non-commissioned officers
develop the feeling of responsibility we
want to give them ownership
i suggest doing this during field
exercises
by suddenly and and unexpectedly
declaring the commander a casualty
and placing the second in command in
charge something we did all the time
in seal training oh got a good platoon
commander he's doing a great job cool
you're down oh platoon chief's doing a
super job cool you're down
the commanding officer of the 119th
infantry in germany makes this statement
in battle
nothing is more important than having
leaders who will
share their commander's responsibility
for the accomplishment of the mission
again if you're a junior person out
there if you're
joining an organization or you're a
mid-level manager if you can be a person
that
starts to take ownership of things and
starts to take pressure
and jobs and tasks and responsibilities
off
your boss's plate they are going to love
you
nothing more important he says nothing
more important than having leaders that
will take
their share of the commander's
responsibility one of the
most difficult tasks for the junior
leader is getting the men
to move forward under fire
issuing the orders is easy but seeing
that the orders are carried out
may call for every ounce of energy and
initiative
the officer or nco possesses
issuing the orders is easy that's the
easy part
i think patton said ten percent of the
job
is issuing orders ninety percent is
getting them done
responsible leadership in actions the
next section caps captain
sauder was at his command post cp
when a soldier came in to report that
two wiremen had been wounded by a enemy
sniper about 500 yards away he
immediately took
four men and set out to assist the
wounded men before arriving at their
goal
the captain and his men observed a group
of wire men pinned down
in an open field by enemy machine gun
fire
captain sauder spotted the enemy machine
gun and ordered his men to covered
positions but himself
took an exposed position from which he
could fire upon the machine gun
he opened fire suddenly and killed six
of the enemy crew making it possible for
the wounded men to be evacuated
in safety and for the wire men to
continue their work by that time captain
sauder
had observed more serious trouble in the
vicinity an enemy armored car
was parked beside a building some
distance away
the captain knew that part of another
advancing regiment was in the sector
covered by the enemy vehicle
he immediately sent back for a
50-caliber machine gun at the command
post
and for two tanks to cover the oncoming
regiment during its approach
while waiting for these reinforcements
he collected a few of his men
and resumed fire on the enemy with the
result that many were forced to flee and
enemy were wounded while this was going
on captain souter was
informed that all officers of one
company with the approaching regiment
had become casualties
he immediately took charge and
reorganized the company so at the
when the other officers came up the unit
was well dispersed and under control
he then gave first aid to the wounded
officer officers
and saw that they were evacuated to a
safer location
for further care the tanks arrived in
time to assist the other regiment's
assault on the enemy positions and the
objective
was successfully taken had it not been
for captain sauder's timely and decisive
actions
casualties among our men would have been
extremely heavy and the attainment of
the objective questionable
for his contribution in this emergency
captain sauder was awarded the silver
star
initiative taking charge i love this
part where he got wounded there's a
company coming forward and they're
wounded officers
so you disperse your company and you
prepare to receive those guys and you'll
be able to put them to work immediately
responsible leader leadership as the
soldier sees it
another fine example of responsible and
inspiring leadership is given
in the following account of
the part played by lieutenant william e
everett 101st
infantry 36th division in action in
italy
this account was written by three of the
enlisted men who served
under him during that action our company
led the attack
on a hill and took it the enemy
counter-attacked laying down heavy
artillery
mortar and machine gun fire that knocked
out a large number of our men and every
officer
except lieutenant everett
damn lieutenant everett took over the
difficult and dangerous job of keeping
the company
under control without any communications
whatever
he had become so short of men that even
the runners
had to stay on the line fighting hard to
help hold the ground we had won
at the time lieutenant everett took
charge the enemy were coming up three
sides of the hill
and our men were in trouble the
lieutenant ordered us to open fire with
everything we had
while he took an exposed position on the
side of the hill and called fire orders
to
our mortar our mortar finally stopped
the advancing enemy
he then located an enemy mortar that had
been giving us trouble all day and
adjusted our mortar on it
knocking it out with a direct hit on the
third round he personally eliminated two
enemy snipers
who had wounded several of our men it
was largely through his daring and
determination
that we were able to beat off the strong
enemy counter-attacks
for three days and four nights he risked
his life by going from one platoon to
another
under enemy machine gun fire keeping the
men under control and helping them
meet each problem as it came at times he
himself
helped carry the wounded to safer places
the lieutenant was sick during all this
fighting
yet he never thought of his own
discomfort but
stuck by the men who might have lost out
if it had not been for his leadership
leadership is the most important thing
on the battlefield
next section discipline the first
function of leadership
you know i'm happy and smiling when i
see that
in the frequent discussions of
battlefield leadership we are often
prone to overlook the first
function of leadership the development
of unit and individual discipline
the battle is the payoff
said lieutenant colonel ralph ingersoll
and it
is exactly that the payoff on the
leadership which welded individuals into
a smoothly
functioning team discipline applies to
all
captain jack gary company commander of
the 11th
infantry writes discipline is sometimes
the determining factor between winning
and losing
i once listened to a wounded officer
back from fighting in africa who said
forget all the formalities in the field
forget the officer and nco distinctions
in the field
keep all the eight balls they will fight
like hell and i tried to
i looked up this term eight balls and
i i assume it means like uh um like a
rebel type guy
the reason i assume that is because the
next sentence says so that that was the
guy quoting someone from africa he says
i do not believe he had seen very much
action or he would not have made such a
statement
i had a few quote eight balls who did
fight like hell but i have also had a
lot of men who never caused me trouble
who were quiet confident well
disciplined and these men fought much
better
so you know you get that uh in case of
war break glass
yeah thing where look this guy's a
little rough around the edges
right yeah it seemed like when he was
like i i also had guys who were quite
calm
disciplined or whatever it just seemed
like this eight ball phenomenon was the
opposite of that
yeah they're like the troublemakers yeah
they're a little bit a little bit wild
now look we gotta have those guys too
we're gonna need those guys
and they are they do have it they can be
awesome
for sure because you gotta have a little
bit of that
i mean let's face it if you're joining
the military
if you're joining the military to go
into combat arms or you're joining the
military to go into special operations
you're going in that you want to do
something that's you basically want to
do things that are not
legal in the world like you're going to
kill people you're going to blow things
up you're going to
plant bombs that's what you're going
through yeah you can't really do that
anywhere else yes that's that's
you you know you're a kid and you're
like what do i want to do when i grow up
doctor yeah
lawyer yeah banker yeah
blow things up and kill people that
sounds like a good one
right that's not normal i understand yes
fully
i had a conversation with a guy the
other day and he was like telling me
that
um he was having a conversation with a
guy that was a ceiling he's like you
know there's something that made me
nervous
because when this guy was a young seal
he said you know what
i was asking him hey you know you you
you think you're ready to kill people
and you know you're you're gonna deploy
this was kind of as iraq was going on
and this was like a younger seal that
was gonna be heading to iraq and
the young seal was like oh yeah i'm
ready i want to kill people
and he's you know the guy says you know
it just seemed a little bit it seems
like it shouldn't be like that
and i was like it's like that bro
you ask you know a front line
infantry grunt whatever well i can't i
can't speak for all them you talk to
most a vast majority of seals
and you say hey if the enemy presents
themselves an opportunity if the enemy
if there's an
opportunity for you to kill the enemy
will you be
is happy the right word will you be
will you hesitate in the moment of truth
they'll be like one negative
they'll be stoked so that's the reality
so
there's a little eight ball yeah you
know
let's face it he's down for the cost
yeah now that's
that's the thing is the
very good soldier that you want has that
capability but
has the discipline to keep it under
control the whole uh
the little clip you made of jordan
peterson and i talking about the dang
the
the good man is a dangerous man who has
their their their danger and their
aggression
under control under through discipline
voluntary
under voluntary control that's what
we're looking for that's what we're
looking for yeah
actually that's what we're looking for
next section discipline is based upon
confidence
only a few hours later after he had lost
both legs in combat
lieutenant tichenor who had acted as a
platoon leader in 5th division 12th army
group
made this comment to a military observer
our officers
have to be real leaders discipline in
combat depends
largely upon the men's knowing that the
officer in charge of them
knows his business and is not reluctant
reluctant to take necessary risks
a battalion commander of the sixth
armored division in france makes a
similar combat
comment unless the officer or nco knows
his job completely
the men have no faith in him unless the
men have faith in their leaders
their battle discipline will be poor
so when they're talking about discipline
there they're like are you is the team
going to
do what they need to do when they get
when they get the orders to do it
and if they have faith in the leader
they'll do it and if they don't guess
what
which is interesting because you think
well you know it's the military it's the
military and if they get ordered do
something no
that's what they're talking about here
that's what they're talking about it
doesn't work like that doesn't work like
that anywhere
just because i bark and order at you and
i have rank over you doesn't mean you're
going to do it especially if it's going
to get you killed
there's a comment here and in these
books they just they the
sort of the authority chimes in the
author or whoever the author is
the authors chime in and they just write
comment and it says comment a leader who
has not
gained the respect respect and
confidence of his men
during training has two strikes again
when he against him when he enters
combat
the element of doubt in the minds of his
men may be the difference between
success
and failure of a mission gaining respect
and confidence of your men how do you do
that
do that by barking at him no you do that
by yelling at them no
you do that by listening you do that by
treating them with respect
here is a definition of discipline says
colonel e l
munson signal core true discipline is
voluntary it is based on knowledge
region a sense of duty and idealism
a good leader develops in his men a
cheerful and willing obedience that
wants to respond that wants to carry out
his orders
this kind of discipline will in the end
bring combat results as no other kind
possibly can we could probably stop
right here
because everyone thinks when the
military talks about discipline
they're talking about the way if you can
beat your people into submission
then you're going to be good to go no
that's not the kind of discipline we're
talking about cheerful
willing obedience that's a totally
different thing
willing obedience people want to carry
out the orders
totally different you don't really think
of discipline
associated with cheerful
yeah the context that they're using is
military discipline is like hey
do the does the team respond and execute
what they're told to do with discipline
right
so in the context of that
we there's multiple ways to achieve that
one of them is by beating people
that you're going to do this and you
beat them and they're afraid and they're
doing it out of fear
the other way is they're doing it
because they understand because they're
part of it
the result is the result is similar
but what this guy is saying is that
the one that will bring comrade results
like no other kind is the kind where
it's a positive discipline yeah when
they're
saying it's a self-imposed discipline
we're
doing this because we want to yeah not
because someone's barking at us
this little section here it's uh
replacement instruction
the wrong kind so in in in world war ii
you had guys get wounded guys getting
killed and there was replacements coming
in
and so this happens in inside all
organizations as organizations grow you
got to bring in new people
and as new people come in what happens
to them replacement orientation right
this is like new hires
how do you treat your new hires here's
some things that they did it's called
the wrong kind
a lieutenant comments on his ominous
introduction to frontline existence
on my way to the front as an officer
replacement i met several individuals
who had come back from the front line
invariably they recounted to me their
hair-raising experiences
their outfits had been wiped out or
pinned down for days
officers didn't have a dog's chance of
survival etc
one platoon sergeant went statistical on
me
he said his platoon had lost 16 officers
in one two week period
i expected confidently that i would be
blown to bits within 15 minutes after my
arrival to the front
went statistical yeah that's when you
know they're going hard yeah
uh later experience has shown me that
enlisted men who come
in as replacements are subjected to
similar morale breaking tales i've tried
to get my old men
to give the new replacement a break by
being careful not to exaggerate their
battle experiences
or in any way distort the picture of
frontline existence
give the new men a common sense
introduction to the combat zone and
there will be fewer men going
on sick call before an attack non-comms
and privates
of company k 11th infantry draw
attention to the same
problem our replacements come to us
filled with tenseness and dread
caused by stories they have heard in the
rear special instructors from the front
should be used
at replacement centers to talk to the
new men to talk the new men out of this
unnecessary panic of course the soundest
remedy is to have the replacements
occupy a defensive position for a time
but even
then the kind of treatment they are
given upon arrival at the front
makes a big difference in the amount of
good they will do to their new outfit
so how are we treating people that show
up at your company and you can have such
a huge influence
if you do a good job bringing someone on
board
in a squared away manner don't screw it
up
comment company commanders and platoon
leaders should meet
orient and indoctrinate all replacements
so that they gain an authentic picture
of current battle conditions
this should be done even though battle
indoctrination has been started in
replacement centers
knowing what to expect even when even
when the expected is bad
is better than not knowing and and
consequently
imagining the worst that's what's going
to happen
we're gonna freak out and and part of
this is i think unintentional when
people tell
stories right if you're to tell me
let's say you were in a jiu jitsu
tournament and
you wanted to tell me about something
that happened
that happened to you maybe you got
caught in a guillotine
and look you were connecting and it was
bad right
and you got out of it but it was a like
crazy
when you when you want to tell me that
you want to make me
feel how you felt and one of the ways
you can
kind of get closer is by making a little
exaggeration
bro i started seeing i started the wall
started coming in bro
and it might not necessarily i
understand what you're doing i
understand why you're doing it but
you weren't really going to get choked
out you were just in a good guillotine
but it wasn't good enough because
obviously you got out so people can
exaggerate for the purpose of
of of giving the feelings that they had
you know this mortar like i've been
martyred before
mortar hits mortar hits i don't know i
don't know what the closest mortar to me
ever was but maybe let's call it 20
yards or something like that
yeah so that's close bro that rocks your
world you're like
damn and if i'm just telling you this
bro i got mortared i want you to feel
like so i might be stupid practically
right on top of me it's 20 yards away
bro yeah yeah you're right and if you
don't kind of take the you know a lot of
times we'll take that personal
you know like brian don't don't lie
don't lie to me and exaggerate like that
you know like be accurate kind of thing
but you can't when you really think
about it it makes sense because
if you're like unless you're some if you
got mortared like
a thousand times you know when it's 20
yards you know oh you don't have to
exaggerate to me because i know
but you know most people i can't yeah if
i was talking to someone else
i'd be like oh bro you've been more than
for hell yeah oh yeah i was over here oh
yeah
man this one landed close it was like 20
yards away you'd be like damn i don't
need to
explain it to you but if you don't know
yeah exactly right and i start making
you know i start making it seem like a
little bit well basically you want them
to
understand how you might exactly but
because
and they don't they don't have the
capability to understand what you felt
because they weren't there
you know something you can imagine like
oh yeah if i was there i'd do this like
you have a misrepresentation
of how it would actually feel in the
situation that's natural
exactly right but when you're in the
situation yeah you can tell me
i've never been murdered before i know
surprising but i haven't if you
were like hey yeah we got mortared and
it was crazy it was 20 yards away i'd be
like
i know how 20 i know how far 20 that's
not that close yeah that's like
that'd be all right oh yeah whatever
that's like half of a 40-yard dash like
bro that's kind of far yeah that's not
scary at all but
you know given what you explained it
it's not like that bro you
in that situation you're you think
you're gonna die or whatever you know
um but yeah so that's a natural thing if
you're not in the situation you can't
feel it you never can so
let's put a little slice on top of us
bro
it's basically get the standard of
understanding up to where it needs to be
for me to convey the story you know
that's what we got to watch out for so
be careful with that
then it goes into the right kind of
orientation poor orientation of
replacements may seriously affect the
fighting ability and survival chances of
men themselves and may also endanger the
unit with whom they first serve
for these reasons leaders of platoons
squads and companies
should find out exactly what orientation
and training have been given
the men and should provide essential
orientation on the spot
insofar as practicable before
sending them into combat if a divisional
training plan
similar to that described below is in
operation the problem of inducting new
members
new men into smaller units is much
simplified and lower
unit orientation can be modified
accordingly and then there's an
effective
an effective training system described
our division
has received thousands of replacements
since at first since its first combat
experience in normandy
more than 90 percent of these
replacements have been infantry
many of the replacements came into the
division lacking confidence in their
ability and paralyzed by the
apprehension and engendered
by loose talk before and upon their
arrival this exact
guys are scared shitless
some time ago we started a course of
instruction for our replacements
it lasts two and a half days and is
conducted by battle
experienced personnel particular
emphasis
is placed upon how to live in a foxhole
development of an aggressive attitude
the use of fragmentation grenade
anti-tank grenade and bazooka
throughout the course these men are
trained in groups of 12 they are later
assigned to organizations by these same
groups
you know what else you got to tell
people about is
it closes out here by saying we we found
that this course of instruction gives
replacements much greater
self-confidence it debunks the notions
that they have picked up in the rear
the course has definitely improved not
only the morale but also the fighting
ability of our replacements
who expect to continue the plan for all
replacements to come to the division
you know what else you gotta tell people
like oh you're gonna be nervous um
yeah but it's okay you're gonna be
nervous it's no big deal everyone's
nervous no big deal
it's fine that helps a lot because i've
seen this with fighters
they get nervous and they don't know
what nervous feel like even really
experienced
athletes that might have wrestled or
they might have you know boxed or they
might have done smokers or they might
even have
a decent mma record but now they're
going in the ufc and they get nervous
for the first time
and they don't know what that they don't
know that feeling and all of a sudden
they think it's bad
yeah something's wrong and you got to
say hey listen oh you're
feeling a little like queasy right now
feeling some butterflies that's good
that's your body putting your blood into
your muscles
instead of to your stomach it's all good
common failings
says a successful third army rifle
company commander the following failings
are common among replacements they must
be strictly and promptly eliminated if
excessive casualties are to be avoided
and combat efficiency
obtained lack of ordinary discipline
saying yeah
instead of saying yes sir
jumping at the sound of every outgoing
or incoming artillery shell
[Music]
we acted like we were like straight up
nom like
that's in ramadi like when the guys
would show up and sometimes there'd be
outgoing artillery from camp ramadi yeah
and you'd see guys freaking out it's
outgoing we'd like
we're all just hardcore actually that's
so much fun with that
i was gonna ask like is that a thing
because like you know when you first
encounter gunfire even if it's like you
know
the guy next year or whatever shooting
outgoing you know as we say
um it can startle you if you don't hear
that all the time yeah it's so loud
so i'll be like this at the gun range
bear with me
i know so at the gun range you know when
you first when you first go
in you start hearing the the boom and
then you know you got a little jump you
know but after a while you go a few
times or whatever it's like
you don't jump at all but then let's say
you take your friend if it hits his
first time or something like that first
time long time whatever
and you see him jump and then is that a
thing like ah you jump you're kind of
like
you know you're gonna get startled i
mean you'll get startled but you do get
used to it
yeah fully but what i'm saying is let's
say me and you go to the gun range
somewhere or you know coronado whatever
and
like boom you know shots fired whatever
like downrange or whatever and i'd like
jump are you going to tease me is that
the culture you know kind of like
like why are you jumping for it you know
kind of thing you're asking if i'm going
to tease you yeah the answer is yes
that's kind of a universal thing right
good yeah yeah
um but but you do get used to it
but still like a startling noise but you
get
you get used to i mean we shoot a ton in
the seal teams oh yeah just like
so much yeah it makes sense and again
yeah i you know
i haven't shot in a ton in the seal
teams but when i go to the
the range it's the same thing on a
different scale where yeah when you
first go in you're like boom or when
like you're about to shoot and hear the
guy next you shoot you're like oh [ __ ]
you know did my gun go off or whatever
it's like
so i hear that so if you don't hear that
question i heard mike
this is not very reassuring bro you know
i just hear
and then but then after a while it does
it doesn't affect you
i figure that's natural regardless of
the environment you know
did did jason gardner tell that story on
the podcast where the guy
they were doing a debrief they're doing
a debrief so jason garner's
like at team 5
and they're doing a debrief after like a
cqc killhouse run or something
and this young officer standing there
during the debrief
and he just cracks off around like
during the debrief supposed to be
cleared and safe
he cracks off around and goes between
two of the guys they're standing in a
circle he cracks off around
yeah and the dude had like an out of
body experience and he looks up at the
group and he says
he was decocking him he says he was
decocking it as if it wasn't
him that's one of my favorite stories
from gardner dude because that tells you
how people get crazy
they do something and they think that it
wasn't even them just make making excuse
for a
person that is someone else he was
decocking it
so there you go jumping at the sound of
every outgoing or incoming artillery
shell
uh here's another good one stoner was
stoner's
uh task unit was going through cqc
training
and this guy threw a crash into a room
and it like he threw a crash into the
room
and then went in the room and then like
backed out because he was scared to
crash because it's something weird like
that where the guy was basically scared
of the crash
and so stoner was watching and so
storm's like
they get done with the run and someone's
like hey come with me and and stoner
got like seven crashes in his pocket and
he went into like a small
closet and he goes and he starts talking
the guy all
normal and like like hey you know i just
want to talk and as he's pulling the
crash out just
undoes it and pulls pulls the pin and
just drops it at their feet and
continues talking totally normal just
like
oh man he does that seven times
and then at the end of whatever he was
saying to me goes hey by the way don't
be scared of crashes they're not gonna
hurt you
wait so are they what do you mean okay
they can't hurt you got it but a crash
just goes bang
i mean what are you holding your hand if
you hold your hand it could hurt you
yeah yeah so
it doesn't emit anything yeah it doesn't
have anything it's like a big
firecracker basically yeah i mean look
you don't want to put a firecracker
next to your hand or next to your eye
right right but
they're not going to hurt you yeah i
mean you crash each other all the time
so i always thought that was a good
lesson learned from stoner to that dude
probably not
great for his hearing but oh well
unwillingness to use the rifle many have
been told
never to fire without direct orders for
fear of revealing positions
lack of pride in self organization or
work
poor physical condition a tendency to
bunch together when in danger i wrote
about that in leadership strategy and
tactics
not just from a battlefield but also
from a
mental status we all just want to like
crowd each other we get
we get we feel comfort being next to
each other don't
freezing under fire slaving slovenliness
in care of equipment lack of skill with
the rifle
or other infantry weapons fear of the
night ignorance of squad formations
ignorance of field sanitation
and of personal hygiene in combat
comment
replacements who exhibit these
deficiencies usually
have usually not had the advantage of
such training system as
described above
so think about how you're indoctrinating
your people you can probably do a better
job of it
next section is about river crossings it
goes by this whole
this is these are tactical things trying
to help people win this war
these are tactical things about
literally how to
cross rivers very cool to read i'm not
going to cover it right now it covers
assault bolt handling and and water
safety and foot bridges and cable
bridges and engineer bridges
it just goes on all these detailed
sections
then it goes into this story about
roger young and it's got a song
that's got a song with musical notes
that you can sing
i'm going to read you the the lyrics the
first part of it oh
they've got no time for glory in the
infantry
oh they've got no use for praises loudly
sung
but in every soldier's heart in all the
infantry
shines the name shines the name of roger
young
roger young who fought and died for the
men
he marched among so
this story is about a medal of honor
recipient and it tells a bit of the
story here
that that song is about this medal of
honor recipient
roger young on july 31st 1943 the
infantry company
of which private young was a member was
ordered to make a limited withdrawal
from the battle line in order to adjust
the battalion's position for the night
at this time private young's platoon was
engaged with the enemy in dense
jungle where observation was limited the
platoon was suddenly pinned down by
intense fire from a japanese machine gun
concealed on higher ground only 75 yards
away
the initial burst wounded private young
as the platoon started to obey the order
to withdraw
private young started creeping toward
the emplacement
despite a second wound he continued his
heroic advance attracting enemy fire
and answering with rifle fire
when close to his objective he began
throwing hand grenades
and while doing so he was hit again and
killed private young's bold action in
closing with this japanese pillbox and
thus diverting its fire
permitted his platoon to disengage
itself without loss
and was responsible for several enemy
casualties
like i said roger young
was he received the medal of honor for
this action
and i i looked up i looked up roger
young
is an interesting story he was from a
small town up in ohio to a place called
tiffin ohio
and sometime during high school he was a
really good athlete he was small but
he's a really good athlete
and sometime in high school i think he
was playing either basketball or
football
he got some weird injury some weird
head injury that left him
almost completely deaf and blind
like he could see but not really well he
could hear but not really well
and he was worried about being able to
get into the regular
army so he joined the national guard and
he was like a really good soldier
despite the fact that he couldn't see
very well and he couldn't hear very well
and before this this assault
in new jers new georgia and this island
in new georgia which is in the solomon
islands
before this assault he had been advanced
in rank and he went to his
leadership and requested a demotion
because he felt like he was putting his
guys at risk because he couldn't see
well enough and he couldn't hear well
enough
and at first they thought he's just
trying to get out of the
you know he's just trying to not do this
do this assault
and he said no i'm doing the assault i'm
doing the assault but i shouldn't be in
charge of anyone because i can barely
see and i can barely hear
and they said okay roger that they
demoted him they so he wasn't in charge
of a squad anymore
and he just became a rifleman
went out there and saved his guys
next section is called patrol pointers
commanders and staffs as well as troops
should be made to realize the amount of
detail
essential to proper preparation of a
patrol for each mission
emphasize the fact that the patrol
leader must be given the means to and
time
to accomplish his mission how often do
we actually think about
what we're tasking people with you got
to realize what you're tasking people
with
what time it's going to take how much
time they need to prepare for
contact with the main force leaders of
flank and security or security patrols
should be impressed with the importance
of maintaining contact with the main
force at all times
loss of contact has often proved
disastrous
so you have to maintain communications
the opposite extreme we've got a little
dichotomy going here the opposite
extreme however
can also have serious results one patrol
leader overzealous about maintaining
contact caused the attack to involve the
main body
and develop into a major action for
which the latter was not prepared so
this guy kept everyone so
close that by the time they did the
assault the main body got
caught up in the assault as well so
there's a dichotomy you gotta balance
patrol leadership strictest discipline
must be maintained during a patrol
operation
rigid control should be exercised to
eliminate
unnecessary noise talking sneezing and
most important ill-advised
firing all movement must be regulated to
take full advantage
of conditions such as rainstorms
temporary obscuring of the moon
by clouds etc so this is what we got to
remember
when we say strictest discipline has to
be maintained
and control if you and i are on a patrol
and you're in the back of the patrol and
i'm the you're the rear security
and i'm the pl i'm the patrol leader and
i'm number two so there's
14 18 22 guys between us how do i
control what you're gonna do
i can't and if you see something that
makes you nervous you can start shooting
you know you might start making a call
you might be doing dumb things
why is that because you're dumb no it's
because i'm a bad leader because i
didn't explain to you
what the parameters were of what we were
doing i didn't explain to you why we
were doing what we were doing i didn't
explain to you the dangers of shooting
your rifle if you weren't sure
of what was happening so when they say
control don't think of it like oh i've
got to sit there and tell everyone
exactly what to do you're going to
really lose then
what you have to do is you have to
utilize
powerful and and and well
executed decentralized command that's
what control
is back to the book
one patrol had almost completed its
mission when its presence and location
were revealed to the enemy
through an unguarded movement by one of
the members
this betrayal nullified the entire
effort of that
particular patrol patience is of the
utmost importance in patrolling
that's true the success
or failure of a patrol depends in the
final analysis upon the qualities of
leadership possessed by the patrol
leader
in most cases the commanders have
selected their best
officers and ncos to perform this duty
leadership is what makes a patrol
successful leadership
organizing professional patrols this is
an interesting combat
concept some commanders have gone so far
as to organize permanent patrol groups
whose principal function is to furnish
personnel for battle missions the
officers selected for these groups are
volunteers the most aggressive tough and
rugged officers in the unit
they are permitted to select from the
unit men who possess the same qualities
after a period of intensive training and
scouting patrolling battle drill
and physical hardening the patrol group
is attached to the unit
headquarters from which it receives its
mission so he's talking look you can
make a little element that's
made of your best guys fatigue and
strain endured by battle patrols make it
impracticable to assign them more than
one major mission every two or three
days upon completion of a mission the
men should be moved
to a rear location fed rested and
prepared for the next
what i what i say is interesting about
this is what do you have
in your company that's a duty
or a mission or a task that maybe it's
such of such importance that you put
together a little hit team
and they get good at it and they do it
all the time and you give them the
support you give them the training
that's a very sensible thing to think
about now it doesn't mean you have to
exclude everybody else because i can
have a hit team of four people that do
uh presentations to clients it doesn't
mean i i send two other guys you know
occasionally i throw this guy i throw
this guy so other people learn
and maybe they spend some time in the
hit team but it's an
interesting concept and a good one to
make someone a professional at that
particular
part of the duty i mean you're a
football player that's like what
football is right
special teams essentially right yeah
yeah
i mean it didn't used to be that way
used to be like hey
we're gonna play football everybody's
playing yeah we're just playing football
yeah now it's like only going out with
this place happening
that's an interesting way to look at it
yeah only when this place happens yeah
i mean there's some people that only
play one play yeah
kicker kicker kicker a wedge breaker
something well
that can be kind of versatile um yeah
you're right specialty
brother was this guy actually he was a
wide receiver but
what the heck was his name he played at
uh trade he
and he was just well he was a wide
receiver for sure and he did some things
or whatever but
it was marginal compared to what his
specialty was
was blocking field goals and punts he
was on the outside because he could run
real fast
we have the instinct he was just so yeah
the instinct
and his speed he was the first guy in
the team so the way he could just like
guinness rock
dennis rodman rebounding yeah
you know dennis rodman is right yeah but
i mean it's the scenario is a little bit
different because it's
it's not like they're like hey we need
to call the rebounder you know
james rodman i was just playing you see
him saying but this guy
hey they're about to kick a field goal
hey freaking what the heck was the
matt oh man they're gonna be mad at me
foreign instincts to get that hand on
the ball speed instincts
you know what's weird about this is he
must have been really good to
actually be identified as that guy yep
he totally was he was famous for that
so it was like that the team was like
kind of known for that like hey
buckle up when we kick field goals or
punts like this guy is coming
so there was time they got to the point
where they would stack that side
wherever he was
which is dangerous to do because you
open up the other side for other guys
but
bro it's that important that's so good
that's how good this specialized
um skill he had developed you know
there's something to be said about this
concept and
specializing and focusing on something
um i was watching the thing about wayne
gretzky and when he was like he would
sit there and watch hockey games as a
kid
and while he was watching the hockey
game he would trace the puck
like with a pen on the on the on like a
piece of paper
like he'd draw a hockey rink and then he
would sit there and trace where the puck
went where to go the whole time
and then when the game was over three
periods later he would look at the
where his marks were on this piece of
paper and start to think that's where
the puck is
this is where the puck is most of the
time this is where i need to be yeah
and same with dennis rodman he would
know where different shooters on his
team would kind of spin they put on the
ball
and he'd be able to assess where that
ball was going to go where's the highest
chance
of that happening that's what he focused
on
so if you can do that with a team and
you can get a team
focused on a particular item they're
going to excel at it it's a good concept
and the comment here says the presence
of a professional patrol group in a unit
should not be considered a complete
solution to the patrolling problem
nor should it operate to curtail the
training of individual riflemen in
scouting and patrolling right this
doesn't mean you got rodman so now no
one else needs to work on the rebounding
the professional group should be used
for difficult or special missions
while norming normal patrolling
continues as well
now this section that i'm about to read
this is kind of this is one of the ones
where
when i read these for the first time i
was like this one's kind of
it's a good debrief because it's a
failure
and they actually debrief a mission here
this section is called how not to patrol
and it's got notes in it a sixth army
report includes this account of an
unsuccessful patrol action in new guinea
though some members of the patrol
exhibited splendid courage and
initiative the mission was not
accomplished and casualties were high
the negative results of this patrol
action
were due in large part to several
violations of basic patrol principles
as pointed out below a map of the area
is shown on the opposite page
so the terrain that they're dealing with
there's a section on terrain the coastal
flat northwest river
there's a river and the way the river is
broken out
uh the river is covered with kunai grass
two to five feet hot
feet high interspersed with wooded areas
traveling is difficult and exhausting
trees in the wooded areas are not
close together but the underbrush is
dense and visibility limited so you
already know this is freaking horrible
this is hard terrain to get through a
track paralleling the beach
is about eight feet wide and clear of
underbrush along the beach is a four to
eight foot embankment suitable for cover
against small arms fire from
inland the width of the river varies
from 15 feet
in some places to 35 feet in others
its current is swift the stream bread is
rocky and relatively shallow except for
the main channel
which at the time of this patrol action
was more than six feet deep as a result
of recent rains
so the way this is set up there's
there's like this
they're on an island they got the ocean
it's a beach
there's an outpost that's to the south
end
outpost a and then there's a river mouth
and this patrol goes across the river to
enemy territory
and they've got these various locations
a is the outpost and across the river
you got this coconut
plantation you've got a perimeter that
gets set up and you've got a little
village up there
and they've got all these routes that go
in and out route k they take in route l
one element takes out route and another
element takes out
so there's a lot going on
in this in this patrol and i don't want
to get too wrapped around trying to
explain
like exactly what happened without the
visuals but the patrol consisted of a
rifle platoon reinforced by 260
millimeter motor squads one intelligence
man a radio operator and aid man
second lieutenant why the platoon leader
was in command
first lieutenant x from wise company was
attached to the patrol
as observer and coordinator
comment the higher commander keeps the
accomplishment of the mission in mind
when he selects the patrol leader
the more important the mission the more
careful his selection must be
a good leader should have judgment
initiative
courage endurance and be a highly
skilled leader
the attachment of lieutenant x as
coordinator
not only divided responsibility but also
indicated a doubt in the commander's of
mind as to wise ability to lead the
patrol so you've got
you've got this second lieutenant that's
going out there in command but you put a
first lieutenant with him
it it it doesn't make any sense and
that's what they're that's what their
comment is you're kind of
you're kind of throwing two people if
you if you don't trust one guy to run
the mission don't don't do it
it's just a rifle platoon why are you
sending two officers out there do you
not have confidence in one of them and
if that's the case why are you sending
them out there
important thing to think about and what
does it do to the minds of the troops
hey we here oh well there's the boss
cool oh wait now we got another boss
wait a second why are we getting two
bosses
um the mission the mission of the patrol
is across the river
in vicinity of the battalion outpost
reconnor to the coastal area
um south of this village and destroy any
enemy found right so there you go
but i'm going to read that again the
mission of the patrol is to cross the
river in the vicinity
of the battalion outpost do
reconnaissance of the coastal area
and destroy enemy enemy found
and it says here comment the mission
assigned by the higher commander to the
patrol leader must be specific and
unmistakable
indefinite missions invite confusion
casualties and failures
one patrol cannot be expected to to
execute efficiently
a number of missions and by the way
they're quoting field manuals from this
that's
fm 2175 reconnaissance patrols
are used primarily to secure information
maintain contact with the enemy
or observe terrain they avoid
unnecessary combat and accomplish their
mission by stealth
reconnaissance patrols engage in
firefights only when necessary to
accomplish their mission or to protect
themselves so you see the dichotomy here
we want you to do a reconnaissance but
we want you to destroy any enemy that
you find
that's two different things that's
saying i want you to
fight someone and run away from them at
the same time
a combat patrol executes missions which
they which may require fighting to
accomplish or to help accomplish
every combat patrol secures information
as a secondary mission
then here's the comment this patrol has
been given two primary missions
reconnaissance and combat without any
indication as to which has priority
prioritize and execute we need to know
what the priority is
the directive to destroy any enemy found
in the area if taken as a primary
mission
will preclude successful will proclude
successful operation as a reconnaissance
patrol
the mission should have been either
combat with reconnaissance as a
secondary mission or reconnaissance
alone
in which case the patrol would engage in
combat only to the extent necessary
to complete its reconnaissance mission
so think about that when you're
assigning someone a mission
make sure they understand what the damn
mission is and don't assign them
to missions that are opposed to each
other
and when you do assign people two or
three missions or tasks or projects
make sure they know what the priority
mission is what the priority project is
the patrol departed out of the outpost
to 1015 leaving a
160 millimeter motor squad to furnish
fire support
a rope secured on both banks were used
to help put the patrol weight across the
stream
by 11 15 personnel and equipment had
crossed and we're waiting for scheduled
artillery concentration before moving
forward
at 11 30 80 rounds of 105 was fired
after completion of the artillery fire
the patrol
recon ordered along the route to the
beach
except for the killing of three japs by
the rear point no contact was made and
the trip was uneventful
okay at 1405 the patrol
arrived at sea which is they they
basically patrol from the outpost which
is on the beach
inland a little bit and to the north and
then they get to the beach
up north and they set up a perimeter
that's the point c
that they're talking about for purposes
of command and control the patrol was
divided into three sections
consisting respectively of second
lieutenant y and ten men
the platoon sergeant and thirteen men
and first lieutenant x and twenty men
so now we're dividing
and the comment is actually command and
control were not improved by this
organization
as was demonstrated later lieutenant y
in addition to commanding the patrol
was also commanding one of the sections
lieutenant x as a loot
as a section leader was now under the
command of his junior
lieutenant
so have you ever heard me say you
probably have if you want to be in
charge of
everything you want to be in charge of
nothing so when you're supposed to be in
charge of patrol and then you take
charge of a section
you're not going to be able to control
everything you're going to be focused on
the squad or the section that you're
leading
so that's why you have subordinate
leadership so they can look down and in
and run that little element and you can
look up and out and see what the whole
team is doing together
and you can mutually support each other
and cover and move for each other
at this time radio communications with
the battalion commander at outpost was
established
however radio soon went out did not
function thereafter contact the first
contact with the enemy came shortly
after the reorganization had been
completed about 20 japs with
armed armed with automatic weapons
attacked the perimeter from the
southwest apparently this
group had followed the trail made by the
patrol
in the brief ensuing skirmish ten emmy
were killed and the remainder dispersed
okay they do okay through that one
patrol then moved southeast along the
coastal track toward coconut grove
at b so now they were far up north in
the perimeter now they start moving
south towards this coconut grove when
advanced element of the patrol reached
the northwest edge of the coconut grove
they received heavy machine gun fire
rifle mortar
hand grenade fire from their front and
right flank
so this is a bad scenario crossfire
three members of the patrol were wounded
it was estimated that about 50 enemy
fighters were in the grove
first lieutenant x assumed command and
because the heavy fire ordered the
patrol to return to the former beach at
position
c two the wounded men had been had to be
assisted
after their arrival so now they go back
to this perimeter that they had
after their arrival at sea the firing
stopped and a temporary perimeter
was organized so they they get back they
regrouped they got two wounded
lieutenant x finding the men too closely
grouped ordered two sections to move
forward further inland
neither section moved as far as
lieutenant x intended so he signaled
them to move
further so they're in a perimeter
lieutenant x says hey push out from the
perimeter a little bit
they don't really move far enough so he
gives them a signal
to move further this signal was
interpreted to mean that the sections
were to return to the river via separate
routes as had been discussed earlier
when the patrol first reorganized at sea
because both sections moved out
leaving lieutenant x by himself with his
20 men so now we have complete we have
three different
sections out here three different
elements out there
and you do not want to split forces in
the first place and you definitely want
to split forces into three groups and
you definitely don't want to split
forces into three groups and you got
wounded and you've already been attacked
by a 50 man enemy force this is crazy
the comment the patrol must be directed
regulated and controlled at all times
patrol members must be familiar with all
prescribed signals the leader may
arrange for a few additional signals for
special purposes
in this instance in in this instance the
loss of control
can undoubtedly be attributed to the
poor chain of command in the patrol
organization
to sudden change in command from
lieutenant y to lieutenant x
while the patrol is in contact with the
enemy and to a failure to reach clear
understanding of plans and signals
you can see how these little compounding
problems and if you look at your
organization if you look at what you're
doing inside of your business
what little what little mistakes are you
making
what little what little things are you
compounding what problems do you have
that can be compounding that can lead to
disaster
is it communication is it chain of
command are you not mutually supporting
each other
do people not understand what the
mission is
you see this applies to everything that
we do with any kind of team
the trip back the platoon sergeant with
his 13 men followed root m
so basically they all start going back
in different directions
they crossed the river without incident
and reported back to con so they get
back
this first group of 13 guys gets back to
the to the command post the battalion
command post
second lieutenant y and his ten men made
it wider circuit
and they report back to the battalion
an hour later without having contacted
the enemy
okay so we're doing pretty good but
first lieutenant x realized that the
other two sections had gone he proceeded
to the river to another route and he's
got the wounded guys
one of the wounded died and route the
body was carried
the section reached one point on the
river without difficulty but found the
point of the river that they got the the
river was 30 feet wide
and the current was very swift and it
would have been dangerous
even for ex excellent swimmers an
attempt to reach the original crossing
site
was unsuccessful because the enemy was
in position
because the enemy would they they tried
to go back where they originally crossed
that's where they try and go back to and
guess what the enemy is waiting for him
there
obviously they know how hard it is
across the river they know the crossing
points
patrol should return from this is
comment patrol should return from a
mission over a different route
to avoid ambush alternate crossing
points could have been determined by
reconnaissance
before the combat patrol was sent out
it appears that the enemy allowed the
patrol to cross the river unopposed and
plan to ambush it
by closing in behind
um so now lieutenant x goes back
so they get they get fought away from
the place where they originally crossed
he sets up a perimeter anticipation of
attack by the enemy
a sergeant was then sent out with the
mission of crossing the river and
reporting to the battalion commander
for help the next section is called
the rescue meanwhile the battalion
commander received a situation report
from the leader of the section which
returned
acting upon this information the
battalion commander had formed a group
of 20 men
and had proceeded to the vicinity of
this
island it's another thing that screwed
up and when you see it on the terrain
where this element wants to cross over
they're going to cross the river but
they're going to cross onto like a
little mini island where they'll have to
do
another freaking crossing but they don't
know that because they haven't done
recon
believing that this to be the balance of
the patrol also
so this group was preparing to cross the
river to aid the remainder of the troll
when they observed lieutenant y and his
section crossing back
and so now the battalion thinks oh okay
they're coming back now so we're good so
they all go back
to they all go back to the battalion and
then the battalion figures out the
battalion commander figures out oh
wait you didn't even bring back all the
guy all the guys so two groups have come
back but there's a third group out there
and now the battalion commanders like
trying to figure out what to do so he
goes back out again and again this is
the battalion commander this is a very
senior guy going out to
execute this rescue mission in order to
evacuate and they link up in order to
evacuate the wounded it was decided that
a rope must be used
several attempts by lieutenant x to
cross the river with the rope were
unsuccessful finally but the battalion
commander and four others grasped hands
and formed a human chain out into the
water lieutenant x removed his clothes
and
tied the rope to his waist from a point
upstream he plunged in the river and was
successful in reaching
the hand of one of the men in the human
chain
as he was carried downstream by the
current as the men in the human chain
with the aid of others on the bank were
pulling lieutenant x and the rope ashore
and any machine gun opened up from the
northwest bank although the rope was
eventually secured on the island
one man had been killed and five wounded
including the battalion commander
the wounded were evacuated to the
outpost where the battalion commander
died within an hour
comment although his bravery was
commendable the
inadvisability of a battalion commander
participating in a patrol action is
obvious
subsequently back to the event
subsequently the enemy
subjected the island to heavy machine
gun and mortar fire
however the men on the island this is
that little island of the river
however the little island the men in the
island stayed
in position to cover the crossing of the
remaining 17 men
on the far bank one of the two wounded
men with this group of the 17 was
successfully evacuated but the other was
swept away and drowned while trying to
cross
of the 15 men only of the 15 remaining
men
only eight succeeded in getting across
the river before the japs closed in
these men said they had been subjected
to heavy mortar and grenade fire and it
was believed that the others were killed
so only eight of them make it it is
believed
that all of the uninjured men in the
group could have crossed the river
before the enemy closed in on them had
they not
chosen to stick it out in hopes of
getting the wounded across
so there you go these guys were brave
they wanted to stay with their friends
and they end up losing just about
everybody because they're trying to get
these wounded guys across
the comment the patrol crossed a
difficult obstacle and moved rapidly
deep into hostile territory where the
enemy situation was obscure
so start this whole this whole thing you
start off by going into enemy territory
and in order to get into enemy
territory you're going across a freaking
river
we better have a damn good plan we don't
know what the enemy situation is up
there
and how deep are we going to go like you
know what you do in a situation like
that aquaculture you put
really good fire support on one side of
the river and say all right guys you're
gonna
go go across go ahead if something
happens we got you
we got mortars we got heavy machine guns
that we'll be able to get you back and
by the way we're gonna put a rope around
the first guy
so when you go across the river
something happens we're gonna pull you
right back
that's covered move by the way
and then you don't go on a lengthy
patrol
without good support
there was apparently very little
reconnaissance on the part of the patrol
and it was
unaware of the enemy strength in the
immediate vicinity
the patrol was of sufficient strength to
fight its way
out against the superior number of enemy
but when control
was lost and the patrol was disorganized
and split up it was susceptible to
defeat in detail
and just check this out if you were on
patrol with me
and you saw me give you a hand signal
like to go out set up a
push out a little bit further and you
saw another hand signal with me
from me there would be no part of your
brain that would be thinking i would be
telling you to split forces and go back
to base
no part of your brain would think that
you would know that i would that i would
want to stick together
you would know that everyone would know
that everyone on the team would think
hey the only way we're splitting forces
if jocko comes over and looks at me and
says
hey we're splitting forces here's the
new plan other than that we're sticking
together
that's like an implied commander's
intent from me
always we are sticking together we will
cover and move for each other for sure
but we're not gonna get separated where
we can't mutually support each other
that's not that's not a good thing ever
so what kind of implied intent do you
have with your team
in your organization that people know
what to do
and they won't make mistakes like this
so essentially are you saying like your
example where that's such a rigid
rule that you have because and it's a
stat it would be established
like established like that's kind of the
ether like like if if
life heard me on the radio say like
split for sure
he wouldn't be like hey jock would just
told me to split force he black wait
something something's wrong yeah they
can't
he wouldn't make sense to him gotcha
he'd be like okay hey jonko
say again hey jocko i'm going to come
and talk to you because if you're you've
never
remotely said anything like hey let's
split up and see how we do
right right let's get to for me to say
hey
set up a good cover position cool all
day long
provide cover move to high ground any of
those things but to say
split forces it would be he would need
to he would ask questions right
and you're saying that's because there
are certain things that are when you see
you said implied right but there's
certain things that are just
this is what we're starting let me tell
you what one of them is cover and move
yeah if you get covered move is what i
live by it's a first law of combat
right first of all combat is cover move
if i'm telling you to go away from me
we can't cover and move anymore and lay
fears that and go wait a second jocko
doesn't want me to cover and move that's
crazy something's going on that i need
to understand
or it's a miscommunication he's not like
oh cool later
no it violates one of the principles of
combat leadership
and it's not going to happen so what are
those principles inside your
organization
do you have them established correctly
that people know what to do and if a
weird signal comes through they go wait
a second what are you talking about this
doesn't make any sense
you know like uh dave burke gets a
request from a client
yeah yeah you know and i say
don't give the client any support like
he would be
wait a second know something's going on
here yeah you know something's not clear
there's a miscommunication because we're
here to support our clients
we're here to teach them leadership
we're to give them all the leadership
tools that we can
so and and dave knows that implicitly so
if all of a sudden say don't give them
any support he'd be
well wait a second i gotta go talk to
talk about there's something going on
yeah kind of like if you lost your
temper on somebody
it would be like something would be
confused it wouldn't come yeah it
wouldn't compute right
really you'd be like oh that must be
like a demonstration
or something you know check
uh before we jump to this next section
that
section right there was the section that
i kind of wanted to
that that kind of caught me because it's
a
very good debrief
of a little you know you you know you
read about big battles and we've covered
many big battles and of course we get
we get the gist of the battle or we get
the experience of battle from
one man's vision but to get an
after-action debrief like that
and you can imagine how this is this is
just
one little tiny example one little tiny
example
and and that's why when i
when i started this thing off and i said
you know why do i cover these because i
never heard these lessons
every freaking military leader should
read that
after action report where a bunch of
guys get killed a bunch of guys get
wounded and why does it happen
it's so clear why it happens they give
you the reasons
you have multiple chains of command you
have guys splitting forces there's
unclear communication
like you should know these things you
should get taught these things
and look what else you're facing out
there you got your enemy
right what else you got uh the
river the river oh that doesn't sound
like a big deal but people drowned
yeah this is not this isn't this ain't
like a little stream this is a river
where people
drowned yeah and yeah and that's the
kind of
the assumption for us outsiders where
you know we think of okay they got a you
know they got this many guys on their
side and we got this many guys but we
got this and we got that like we have
these tanks so we got
you know it's like kind of nuts against
nuts kind of a thing
but you consider no no there's there's
like
we need food we need to get across that
river yeah they're all this stuff that's
kind of like
a jungle i mean just the jungle just
getting through there
yeah just what about our weapons or
they're getting
you know sand in them they're getting
wet in them it's raining
yeah we're our feet are rotting we're
starving by the way
we need water we have dysentery like
what is going
on yes and by the way there's a bunch of
japanese
suicidal fighters that want to kill us
all yeah
yeah remember saving private ryan right
where they kind of
you know they they uh they come up on
the beach
and you know everyone guys are jumping
in the water whatever um
and then couple guys they just drowned
like it's like
you know when you you see that opening
shot and you consider it in real life or
whatever it's kind of like okay what are
we about to get into this is going to be
scary
machine guns um you know freaking
germans bombs all this stuff right
but then oh wait a second what about the
actual water
we have to go through like that's going
to kill some of us and imagine this
you go and you make a movie
and you actually go into
the horror and panic
of each individual that jumps into the
water
with 64 pounds of gear they're not a
great swimmer
they go to the bottom panicking fighting
and drowning and dying a horrible death
and that's happening all over the place
on that day
and then meanwhile if you survive if you
somehow
get your [ __ ] together and get your gear
off and now you
get to the beach you're getting freaking
s
strafed by enemy elevated
bunkered machine gun positions
[Music]
check last section of volume seven
is called opncp security
observation post and command post
security
this is such a good start it says even
at this
late date needless casualties
delays and expenditures of effort are
being caused by breaches of open
security rules so what he's saying is
like look we've been fighting this war
for
three and a half four years and even
right now
we have to explain what to do
how to maintain security because we're
taking unnecessary casualties
because people aren't following the
proper protocols the inevitable results
of
of security carelessness are poignantly
illustrated by three
following incidents carelessness cost
lives costs lives reported by technician
5th grade ernest j langey
135th infantry
we stayed in one cp for two weeks
without drawing a shell and it felt
quite secure
for we had been told that the enemy
hadn't been shelling in that particular
vicinity
for the past 30 days
however a few of the men either forgot
or disregarded their instructions they
washed some white towels and shirts and
hung them out to dry
an effective signal for the enemy
artillery fire
upon our command post
three of our men were killed in the
shelling that followed this
breach of security
learning security the hard way reported
by an
infantry battalion commander
after being shelled out of two cp
locations the first time with severe
casualties
we reorganized a sadly depleted
cp group and open for business in
another building
a third-story battalion op in the same
building
could be reached only by passing a large
open window
on a stair landing since the entire
village was
under enemy observation and direct fire
it was necessary to crawl past this open
window
to ensure that this would be done a
sentry was stationed
in the stairway so there's a window you
have to crawl when you go by this window
and it's so important that they put a
guy sitting by the window
going hey freaking crawl buddy hey you
crawl
all went well until it was discovered
that the sergeant major had just covered
the opening with a large
sheet of tin so that the sentry could be
released for work
with the wire team so he needs the
sentry to go do something else so he
says hey just put this piece of tin up
against the window
this might seem like a weird question or
maybe uh
what's a century guard guard yep a guard
as opposed to like you could it's
literally
a guard okay is that like a rank like a
position
or someone like hey you're gonna be a
guard tonight so now you're century
tonight
like that you could you could use the
word guard
and sentry same word okay synonym yeah
century might have a little bit more
tone of military century
as opposed to a guard of a prison
so a sentries more like someone that's
standing watch
gotcha uh so what if you guys are out on
a mission
and it's like a two-day mission whatever
and then it's like okay someone's got to
stand watch
and it's jocko and you're a navy seal
straight up
are you the century for that night kind
of thing we would use the term watch
like hey i got watch
as opposed to saying hey you're on
sentry duty
in the in the navy you generally call it
just
watch so even hey who's got like in the
barracks i'll be like who's got
fire watch or you have watch
because you stand in watch sections on
the ship but technically you're a
century but you're
well like i said it's it's leaning
towards
well we would call sentry duty even in
this in the navy
century duty we'd probably just call it
watch but in other
outfits probably armenian yeah but same
same duty though yep okay so and you
could put obviously this century
was all he was doing was telling people
what to hey get down when you go across
that window right so he wasn't actually
protecting the perimeter
he was protecting the troops from doing
something stupid
yeah but he was a guard in a specific
capacity so there you go ninth century
got it so they put this big tin
sheet up we abandoned the cp in haste
and moved to an already established
alternate cp the only remaining location
in town
the last man had hardly left the
building before it was taken under
direct artillery fire and
rapidly disintegrated this incident
thoroughly impressed our personnel with
the folly of
signaling op and cp locations to the
enemy by altering the outward appearance
of the building after occupancy
that particular error was not repeated
they just got lucky that they
i bet someone was like wait sergeant
major what'd you do you put a piece of
tent up dude we got to get out of here
you're an idiot yeah sergeant major with
all due respect you're an idiot and now
the enemy knows we're here and we got to
get out of here
and the last the last
[Music]
section here one mistake
is too many reported by the commanding
general first infantry division
officers this one is so important
officers visiting the front line units
should be warned against actions that
might reveal to the enemy the locations
of our installations
in one case an observation post was
located in a wrecked building
inside walls of the rooms had been
camouflaged to give a dark background
instruments had been set well back in
the rooms and observers were careful to
move about only in the shadows
all went well until the day some
visiting officers
stopped by they moved about freely
even leaning out of the windows in their
with their field glasses
within a half an hour the building was
completely destroyed by enemy fire
one of our observers was killed
that's the situation when you roll down
to the front lines and you think you're
just going to be
cool yeah and in my mind i'm thinking
i'm not even thinking that they were
being stupid
because they might just be being stupid
but they might also be like hey i'm cool
i'm not going to hide i'm not going to
walk around i'm not going to
i'm not going to hide in the shadows
uh late's got a funny story about going
to the government center for the first
time in downtown ramadi and
they like pull in the humvees and they
see marines sprinting from one location
to another and they're like oh
and they so they just did what they were
doing and like everything cool they're
like yeah there's snipers around here
you've gotta move it
and they're like roger that
um but that that wraps up
this this particular volume volume seven
and you you know that last little
section it's these moments it's these
little moments where we slack off
when we get complacent just for a minute
just for a minute and that's when we get
crushed
we can't let that happen we need to
always stay
on the path speaking of the path echo
charles yes sir
dang that's world record podcast speed
it was good this book had had some
sections that i didn't cover
um because look i
find leadership lessons everywhere but
when we're talking about
using cable footbridge to cross rivers
like i found a little bit of it was
really a stretch okay it was really a
stretch
i kept it to the leadership principles
it's good
so there we go all right how do we uh
how do we stay on the path
well part of this when you know when we
hear these accounts
and go over these field manuals and
learn these lessons from the past from
books whatever it is important to even
just remember to pay attention to the
lessons because you can get caught up in
the story man
for sure like i was kind of concerned
about those guys with the guys
human bridge link chain whatever i was
concerned
you know but there's a lesson that if
you don't
pay attention you might miss it so
that's important too
so yes we're staying capable for sure
we're reading
you know listening all that stuff we are
we're reading i know i'm reading
i'm not sure how much reading you're
doing right now read
either way we're staying physically
capable as well
we're working with us on that one we're
training i'll tell you that
nonetheless we got to keep ourselves
healthy and capable all right that's
important i think
concur so yes so when you're on this
path you might need some supplementation
it helps
oh it definitely helps yeah big time
keep your immunity up keep your
functionality up keep your strength up
keep your endurance
up keep your cognitive attitude up
up yeah big time let it go down
see that's no good for nobody you got
people depending on you
including yourself so you know mostly
yourself mostly yourself it's your drill
could be
others i guess we can't have anyone
relying on us if we can't rely on
ourselves that's what i'm saying that's
what i'm trying to say
what if you're at a capability two
scenarios one you're at a capability
health level
ten and then the other scenario you're
at a health
capability capability level five
you got let's say two kids depending on
you
you got let's say maybe an employee
depending on you
maybe has i don't know some someone else
you want to be level five you want to be
level 10. let's face it that's not even
a really good question it's so obvious
the answer
right but that's but that's not the
point that i'm making the point i'm
making is some of us we're just
like i'm fine with my number five you're
not doing nobody no favors by being at
number five
no at level 10 you are doing a lot of
people some and there's a weird thing
here
some people would rather let let
themselves down
than let other people down some people
would rather they don't care about
someone else but they would not want to
let themselves down
either one of those let's not let anyone
down let's get that level 10 and keep it
this is what i'm saying slipping off the
path and not
getting back onto the path is doing no
good for nobody
mm-hmm and you've got people depending
on you you gotta you gotta do the right
thing
that's what i'm saying yeah let's do it
all right that's what you have
supplementation
as far as supplementation goes jacquard
supplementation jackal fuels called jaco
fuel
jacques.com if you want to get it yep
very reliable very high quality stuff
this will keep you on the path
this will help you straight up so the
first thing we will go into is
discipline
and discipline go supplementation for
your brain and body here's the thing
the days of poison energy drinks which
is the thing i
get it oh it's good energy you know this
thing
but you got other bad stuff in there the
days of drinking neck and stuff are
gone no not no need nope not anymore
it's a big deal now if they when you
drink an energy drink
now yeah it's good for you it's kind of
like what moke did to desserts
right that's exactly what happened what
did the desserts
is what discipline go does to energy
drinks
because let's face it you kind of like
the taste of an energy drink you kind of
like the fact that it gets you a little
amped
what you don't like is you crash what
you don't like is it's bad for you
what you don't like is it you get the
freaking jitters
yeah well and what you don't like is
you're giving yourself type 2 diabetes
which also sucks
suck for sure so there's no reason for
any of that no that's kind of like
dessert
you you feel like crap after you eat a
big whatever
freaking horrible dessert filled with
sugar yeah you just have monk
yeah easy money yeah you you pay an
additional cost for drinking an
energy drink in a traditional sense you
want to hear a non-traditional use of
milk that i've been doing
lately so i used to go to this
restaurant
and they did this thing called dessert
shots have you ever heard of this
concept it's just a really small dessert
yeah but it's kind of cool because
let's face it you get done with a piece
of big prime rib
and a caesar salad and you're kind of
stoked but then you think i kind of want
something sweet too
but i don't want to get a vegan you know
whatever big giant dessert
so i'm just going to get myself a little
little uh
sunday shot at this particular
restaurant i used to go to back in the
day which is closed now unfortunately
because it was a damn good restaurant
me my wife used to go there and stoner
would come like he would just
show up third wheel just come and get it
and hang out
all the time like every time but
lately i've been doing like i'm like the
same thing but i've just been doing
shots of
just maybe a little bit bigger than a
shot but just enough where you're like
yeah you know what
yeah that would work i think now i'll
just keep a mulk mixed up
in the fridge oh yeah and just pour a
little shot
and just get a little hitter mix in some
like dark
chocolate chunks let me get to like this
we haven't done that yet
yeah you put that in the shot so you
like hit it and you can chomp up the
dark chocolate dual hitter nice i'm
telling cause those gourmet
those dessert shots or whatever yeah i
heard that you can get a little tray of
them or whatever and it's like yeah
one's like a little cup
brownie or something they're just small
right you say you're saying
so yeah you want to spice it up make it
more like gourmet and lavish
put some dark chocolate yeah i'm here to
have lavish
i'm here to help also don't worry about
the days of worrying about your joints
just acting up those days are gone too
they are
yeah i'm telling you stay on this thing
the we got joint warfare
mixed with the super krill oil don't
gotta worry about that anymore
yeah those days are gone too good to go
good to go also vitamin d3 keep your
immunity up which is an important thing
maybe you don't think about it every
single day but when you start to get
sick a little scratchy throat whatever
however you get sick
you're gonna be you're gonna notice it
and you're gonna wish you had the
vitamin d3 so
you know don't forget about that kind of
stuff it's important too
yeah yeah what what else no i was
getting everything back into my true
protein in the sense or in the
replacement of a dessert in the form of
a dessert
yeah let's face it it's real good uh you
can get you can get the drink
at wawa if you're on the east coast
which is
you all been crushing it and going
clearing the shelves
keep clearing them let them know what's
up let them see what's up
we're going to florida we're in florida
actually when this comes out we're in
florida we're hitting wawa's date
you know also all the stuff you can get
at a vitamin shop also if you want to
get it
delivered to your house that's going to
cost a lot of money right delivery
no actually it's not going to cost any
money it's going to be free
if you subscribe to any of these items
so you get your
super grill every month you get your
your joint warfare every month you get
your monk every month
so you don't run out and go back in time
to a tool
to a horrible scenario where you wake up
achy
don't let that happen subscribe free
shipping jackalful.com
get some also at origin usa
this is where you can get american-made
goods products i never like
love the word products because it's so
like not we're screwed
pete uses oh yeah pete pete hard goods
right durable durable goods that's right
durable goods oh yeah well they are
durable
they are face it so we got an american
denim boots
jeans uh jiu-jitsu
now we're starting to go into the
fashion stuff because durable goods is
like boots
pants i don't think we're doing fashion
anything
well i know you'd like to think that but
you know
pete and i will have something different
to say about that
nonetheless it's good stuff
originusa.com all made in america from
the beginnings
of the makings of the fabric all the way
till to the
durable goods fashionable or not
that arrive it's all made in america
that's what i'm saying
also choco has a store it's called jocko
store and this is where you can get
durable t-shirts with discipline equals
freedom
and there's a guy i'm like running and
there's a guy
sees me and he's running running at each
other and
he's wearing a uh
nate diaz sweatshirt representing just
you know it it just says represent but i
know i know what that means
that's nate diaz and he sees me and he
reaches down like grabs the bottom of
the nate diaz
sweatshirt represent he pulls up the
shirt
and he's representing while on the path
discipline equals freedom t-shirt
freaking legit oh yeah so i was like
thinking that's
freaking that's like a double double
bonus
scenario not only is this dude down with
nate diaz which is
fully approved dude he's also down with
the cause
which kind of tells me we're aligned
with the whole like that tells me
we're aligned like we we got people you
know
like where it is aligned that is good
and uh and what did you say anything to
him
or he just gave him the bonus no no i
gave him a little bit more than that
i was like hey you hugged him i didn't
hug him because we were running
but i you know held up my fist and we
kind of like high-fived
as we passed each other yeah freaking
legit what's interesting is like
that's the feeling you get whether
you're running or not you see somebody
representing in the wild
well wild let's face it that's it that's
the feeling you get
so if you want to represent in the wild
if you want to represent yeah you can
uh again draculastore.com yeah we got
discipline equals freedom we got good we
got hats we got hoodies we got rash
guards on there
we have a subscription situation free
shipping on this one too by the way
a little bit different kind of designs
more interesting here's the thing wait
t-shirt designs
yeah it's called the shirt locker yeah
you like the name i like the name too
here's the thing about the shirt locker
for peep because people people
are saying hey like can i get that one
design that was like two months ago it's
a good design for sure
we can't that was like if you have the
membership you'll get the design for
that month and then it's sort of gone so
i'm just saying hey i know
i know you want the past one but hey the
future one's gonna be good too
so don't get yourself in a situation
where you're emailing or on twitter or
whatever
saying hey can i get that design just
sign up now you'll get that design
cool check i like where you're at
uh subscribe to the podcast if you
haven't yet also check out jocko
unraveling podcast with daryl cooper dc
dropping knowledge grounded podcast i
talked to dean about getting some of
those back online
warrior kid podcast as well you can also
join us
in the underground at the underground on
the underground
jocko underground.com it's an
alternative podcast we've been talking
about a bunch of wild things on there
things that are not quite jocko podcast
material but they're adjacent material
amplifying material we've talked about a
bunch of psychology we talk about group
dynamics we do talk about leadership
we talk about and we and we've been
doing q a on there as well
so the reason we have that is because we
don't know what's going to happen with
all these platforms that we're on
and we did get we did get some is it
called censorship we didn't get fully
censored but we got some
some warnings on one of the last
podcasts that we did
about the armenian genocide so who knows
we can't i know i do know you know who
knows i know i know that we can't
leave ourselves at the whim of
someone having control over what we do
so we created another platform it's
jockowunderground.com
and if you want to help us build and
maintain that platform
it's eight dollars and eighteen cents a
month there's some layers behind that
but if you wanna help us out then do
that and you can get this
other podcast called jocko underground
you can ask questions and that also
prevents us from having to interject
advertisements about
pillows and um what else
yeah things that you don't want to hear
about probably not yeah
when you press play for jackal podcast
you know what you're going to get and
you're going to get it fast
so hey check it out jock warner hey look
look if you can't afford that
we're we're here we're not trying to
make like this uh
we're not trying to leave people out we
don't want
if you're out there with a freaking nate
diaz t-shirt a sweatshirt and a
and uh disciplinable freedom t-shirt
under your nate diaz sweatshirt
and you can't afford this we're good we
got you covered email
assistance at jockowunderground.com
we'll get you taken care of
we also have a youtube channel which i
am the assistant director on many of
these
really good videos and then echo makes
some other ones too which are marginal
yeah origin usa has one to check out too
we've got some cool stuff on there
check out those youtube channels it's
true also psychological warfare then
album will track some chocolate getting
us three more moments of weakness
seems repetitive when i say it but it
doesn't it kind of like undervalues
really what it is
i'm telling you so some people listen to
music
when they work out some listen listen to
podcasts good all good moves
but if on those days let's face it they
do come
from time to time we're like man i
really don't feel like doing this put in
this put in the psychological warfare
you'll be in you'll be
in the game 100 results on that one by
the way
i just had to go statistical on you
right now with statistical
100 flipsidecanvas.com my brother dakota
meyer
making freaking awesome stuff to hang on
your wall that will also keep you on the
path
i written a bunch of books final spin
i don't know if i'm gonna win this
argument with my publisher
but i'm trying to get where it says
first edition
i'm trying to get it to say first a dish
and i don't know there's
there's legal requirements about that
page you know it's like copyright stuff
so i don't know if i'm gonna be able to
get away with it but we're gonna try
at a minimum it's gonna say first
edition it might even say first a dish
uh i've just finished the what they call
first pass edits
and you're just going through making
sure that you know making sure that the
edits are proper make sure that's all
good to go
and how many edits do you go i mean how
many sorry passes
four it's ridiculous but here's the cool
thing
that book i'm reading it and i'm
freaking loving reading i'm like
and i get the same thing i used to have
this with way the warrior kid when i'm
reading it
and i kind of forget that i wrote it
because
it's fiction so i didn't live it where
you know when i'm reading extreme
ownership
or leadership strategy and tactics it's
very much me
yeah right this is it's me that wrote it
but you're kind of it's a story right
that's in my head
that's almost a different part of my
brain now look it's obvious i think it's
real obvious that it's me that wrote it
you know i was on lex for you know lex
friedman yeah i just did a podcast with
him
and he said that i speak
like russian language like so however
the russian language is
yeah which you can kind of guess when
you hear a russian person speak english
you know send location like that kind of
thing
he says that i speak english as if i'm
a russian human
so that book is definitely written in a
very let's say
lean lean methodology
uh but i'm stoked it's coming out if you
want to get that first to dish
order it pre-order it of course the the
publisher
you know they don't understand they're
not they're they're
not gonna print enough and then there's
going to be people that get second a
dish
brutal and then when you when i sign the
second edition
i'm i'm gonna do it right i'm gonna do
it
good that's good but let's face it i
might not even say anything but you're
gonna know and i'm going to know yeah
you're going to know what i'm going to
know and it's it's going to be
uncomfortable
we're not going to like it but when you
it's sort of like when you got that
first to dish
like let's face it we kind of have a
connection
[Music]
so check it out the book is called final
spin you can pre-order it right now
leadership strategy and tactics field
manual the code evaluation protocol
displays freedom field manual
wayne the warrior kid one two three and
four mikey and the dragons about faced
by hackworth
extreme ownership dichotomy of
leadership the ogs echelon fronts my
leadership consultancy
go to ashlandfront.com if you want us to
bring these leadership principles into
your organization
hit us up that's what we do ef online
which isn't revamped
we've just released some new courses you
can take a course
about each chapter of extreme ownership
we get granular on those
and we're on there live all the time
well not all the time but multiple times
a week you can
ask me whatever question you want go to
efonline.com
the muster we are executing
orlando completed completed
next up is phoenix august 17th and 18th
then las vegas october 28th and 29th
it's on
it's on it's on
um can i declare cove it over i guess i
don't have the power to do that
but i can say that i've been doing live
events i can say that people are
vaccinated or whatever
and we seem to be rapidly approaching
the way things used to be and i'm on
board for that ef battlefield
i'll let you know the next time that
goes down and if you want to help
service members active and retire their
families gold star families check out
mark lee's mom mama lee she's got an
awesome
charity organization and one of the
primary things that she does is she gets
medical treatments for service members
most of them seals one of the big things
she does is
is get people these awesome treatments
in
pure oxygen hyperbaric chambers they do
like month-long treatments pay for the
whole thing
put people up in hotels so they can get
it done it's been hugely helpful to all
kinds of people
so if you want to help with that she
does a bunch of other things too that's
just the tip of the iceberg
america's mightywarriors.org
and if you want more of my historical
harangues or you need more of echo's
bewildering babble and you got some
today
[Laughter]
that opener that opener was you know
that opener question
what the extreme ownership is
bewildering okay we'll say we'll say
well if you want more of that you can
find us on the interwebs on twitter on
the gram and on facebook that goes
adequate charles and i am at jungle
william thanks to everyone out there in
uniform around the world right now
putting all these lessons learned
to use to protect our freedom and the
same goes to the people here on the home
front
our police law enforcement firefighters
paramedics emts dispatchers correctional
officers border patrol secret service
and all first responders thank you
for your sacrifices to protect us
here at home and to everyone else out
there
remember that the first function of
leadership
is discipline and that discipline starts
with yourself
it is us we have to train
we have to prepare we have to harden
ourselves
through suffering and while it hurts and
it does
hurt it is that discipline
that will ultimately bring us
freedom so go out there
and get after it and until next time
this is echo
and jocko out